this video is sponsored by ridgewallet
now that i'm completely up to date with
the series i think it's appropriate for
me to finally be able to say and for
memory sake
one piece is the best series i've ever
read in my entire life
almost half a year ago today i promised
i'd meet all of you
on the shores of wano and now i'm here
and finally i can say that i'm caught up
with one piece once and for all
and i'm both relieved and happy to say
that one oh is for me
on track to being the best arc in the
entire series
everything from its scene selection to
its characters to its dialogue and to
its artwork
wano is an arc that is quite literally
giving us oda at his absolute best
and i cannot wait to discuss that today
this has been a humbling experience and
one i won't soon forget
oh also i hope you stay until the end
because myself and my editor decided to
throw in
something a little different with that
out of the way for the final time
until act 3 completes i'm totally not
mark and these are my first impressions
of
thoughts on and review for the timeless
the spectacular
and the shocking one-o act three
[Music]
before i jump into this i think it's
important for me to say
that this arc is without reservation or
hesitation
the single best arc i think oda has ever
written oda could quite
literally print nothing but blank pages
for the next 50 chapters
and i would still say that this is
easily the best experience
i've ever had in all of one piece
never and i mean never in my life have i
ever been so blown away by a portion of
storytelling this
is honestly nothing like anything i've
seen from oda before
in fact most of it doesn't even have any
of the main characters
it's a harrowing tragic and painful look
back through the history of wano
viewed through the perspective of
kinemon and odin himself
as they live their lives to the bitter
end i cannot
begin to describe the feelings this
section of the story instilled within me
but i will try my best to do that today
join me on this journey through where i
believe to be the single best part of
any fiction i've ever read
in all of my life chapters nine five six
and nine five seven
as has become a trend across the three
intermission sections between acts one
two and now three oda has elected to
fill us in on all the goings-on
surrounding the reverie and the days
following from it but what i liked most
about this particular one was how it
played with our expectations
generally speaking a reader likes to
look for a pattern for which to derive
meaning so in the case of these
intermissions we sort of isolate them
and recognize them
as they concern the events outside of
the main story that are only covered in
these single chapters
before we return to wano with luffy and
the others oda is
fully aware of this and this chapter
largely concerns the reactions from
major players like blackbeard taking
action in response to how things are
unfolding after the reverie
why this is an effective way to open the
chapter is down to anticipation oda
knows that while we're reading this we
are also recalling the events of the
prior intermission chapter and so
this big news we are awaiting surely
must be concerning the revolutionary's
efforts marching on marijuana and while
there is a certain foreboding tone
concerning the fate of sabo
it's most definitely not the main
takeaway from this chapter not even a
little bit also
i'm not willing to count sabo out just
yet the kids bounce back already from a
supposed death situation so
why not again instead this chapter fills
us in on the decisions the world
government have come to concerning
get this the dissolvement of the
warlords of the sea
leading to the likes of buggy mihawk and
even boa hancock being cornered so while
luffy and co
are toughing it out inside 104 survival
the rest of the world is
eating itself alive lord knows what
it'll look like once luffy leaves wano
and what's more is
i wonder how much stronger luffy will be
by the end of all of this
this intermission however is also
noteworthy as it is the first of three
intermissions to be more than one
chapter long with the second concerning
the history of an impossibly large-scale
battle which
was briefly mentioned by garp in the
last intermission before in act
ii in it sengoku details the events
surrounding the rock's
pirates
captained by the imposing and impressive
rocks himself
what's perhaps most noteworthy regarding
this instance is that his crew was
made up of individuals such as kaido big
mom
and whitebeard which honestly adds nice
context to the panels whitebeard was
seen in as a young man
way way back towards marineford as that
crew that we saw in the background that
he was engaging with could very well
have been the rocks pirates in its
heyday
and honestly reading this chapter was
the most engaged i'd been in in quite a
while while reading one piece
and it's with great reason we get the
backstory albeit in a vague sense of
garp and how he became a renowned war
hero taking down the dangerous rocks
pirates alongside
celestial dragons and rogers crew i'm
serious the makeup of this story
sounds like it would make for a
ridiculously engaging film it also
seemed as though all the emperors of the
sea we are familiar with have come from
the rock's pirates crew or some
subsidiary from it blackbeard coming
from whitebeard who came from rocks
which leaves just red-haired shanks as
the odd one out
who they refer to as the chief of his
crew which on its own is a strange
choice of terminology that must have
some sort of hidden meaning behind it
somewhere but what's more is that now we
know that shanks was named an
emperor of the sea six years ago which
would mean i think he became an emperor
shortly before he met up with ace in the
wilderness
i wonder what he did to gain that sort
of reputation and speaking of reputation
we get shown and filled in on the
biggest bounties currently in
circulation
and even some from history we get to see
roger and whitebeards which are
ridiculously high as well as the current
bounties for
the current emperors during these scenes
it appears the government is skittish of
the new alliance made between
kaido and big mom an alliance that could
very well be
the makings of the most powerful crew
ever created
now i hope you guys didn't mind that i
didn't care too much about the bounty
numbers specifically
but more so the hierarchy they were
outlining with that said it was cool to
see where roger and all the other
emperors of the sea were at
at the time diving now into the main
portion of the story however i knew
something
big was about to happen having been
greeted by imagery and talk of goldie
roger as well as knowing full well that
the rebellion was today
my expectations were sky high for this
third act
which the act itself opens proper as
more beautiful autumn imagery displays
itself throughout the pages of the story
gorgeous sprawling shots of the harbor
as well as festivities as orochi leaves
kyoshiro
in charge of the capital while he shoves
off to onigoshima the opening to this
is incredibly effective as such because
one second there's positive
uplifting gorgeous weather surrounded by
celebrations and smiles
and then you turn to the next page
crashing dark waves smashing and
swirling angrily before the samurai who
are pictured
very small this was a stupidly effective
opening and one i thought was extremely
interesting
having already established a plan of
action long ago this should be the
moment where they put it all into
practice but
something's wrong there's no one here
the straw hat crew
all of their allies and all of the
weapons and ships there's nothing to
show for
all of their effort and work and so as
they began this journey
they are once again left all alone with
nothing to show for it
because of this there's a tremendous
amount of foreboding tension that sweeps
across our minds
as momo begs to try another day and
claim on fails to make contact with
anyone all the while surrounded by signs
of wreckage
it's a ridiculously sad and almost
pathetic scene as kinemon screams
desperately into the smell
all to no reply the following chapter
then forces us to watch the prior two
days build up to this harrowing
lonely moment all through the lens of
dramatic irony as we all know how it's
going to end up
everyone seems to be going about their
own preparations but
something comes to orochi's attention
a traitor has been feeding him
information enough information
to destroy the sunny's cave and all the
various bridges linking all the areas of
wano
together no one can go anywhere now
they're all stuck
leaving them exactly where they find
themselves on the coast
looking out to onigima terrified but
duty-driven
i thought it was a brilliant decision to
tell this story all from the perspective
of the akazaya samurai
these are the individuals that have
traversed hell and back in order to save
their home and now while watching these
brave and emotionally exhausted samurai
march onto their certain demise
we as an audience are then cast 39 years
into the past
to bear witness to the best and longest
flashback in the
entire series this is the life and
history of kozuki odin momonosuke's
father
chronicling his story from the age of 18
up until the moment
he died and as the rest of the samurai
instead were cast
20 years into the future
[Music]
immediately obvious from these opening
images is how utterly breathtakingly
beautiful wano as a country was
long before the likes of kaido sunk his
claws into it the land was bountiful
and alive a great choice i thought was
also to tell this story from the point
of view of kinemon partially
it really did go a long way into helping
this be more personal for me seeing him
as a lively young ruffian stealing boars
and causing trouble while also trying to
court his future wife at suru it's a
charming albeit quaint opener to the
world
showing us that even the likes of
kinemon were once young and carefree
before life happened to them
the story's imagery goes out of its way
in preventing us from seeing kozuki odin
for as
long as possible building up to his
eventual unveiling after introducing us
to his father and his advisor running
through the laundry list of
accomplishments and wrongdoings odin has
added to his name since birth
in addition to that we're introduced to
new characters like dengiro and
reintroduced to old ones like hyo
but then we see him cooking a pot of
odin over the cremated remains of
another while totally ignorant of
their shock this is a terrific opening
for the character and one that will
stick in your mind
up until now he's been portrayed as this
carefree spirited ladies man that
desperately wants to leave wano and
explore the world and that's exactly
what we get with him however and
i think most importantly he is a good
person
first and foremost which oda makes sure
to establish
right after we meet him for the very
first time as he defends an entire town
from the rampaging anger of a wild giant
boar
which by the way was all kinemon's doing
but despite that
he takes the blame for everything this
is a tremendous sacrifice
and because of this he is disowned by
his father and no longer is seen
fit to be the shogun of his country it's
this very aspect to odin's character
that leads him to garnering a following
within wano he isn't leading out of fear
or anger or promise for something more
these strong and capable people chose to
follow him because he is a man
of tremendous character well most of the
time there's a wonderful personable
aspect to how this flashback is
delivered there's a warmness to it it
truly feels like a recanting of a
distant memory cobbled together with
then little pieces of public information
and odin's very own journal entries as
he journeys with these newfound
followers from place to place
and peppered throughout this journey are
instances where if given the chance
odin always chooses to put himself
second for the well-being of others
well for the most part this can be seen
obviously through scenes where he
finally meets up with cat viper and duke
dogstorm as they are very young but
being tortured by the people of wano but
perhaps the best and most obvious
example of odin's true nature
is on display after he meets this man
for the very first time
i'm sure you're familiar it's white
people all young and strong and look at
that hair
this scene perhaps more obviously than
any other highlights the deepest desire
of odin
and that is the desire to leave despite
developing a great reputation around
wano through his travels and having been
reinstated as his own father's son
as soon as he hears word that a pirate
ship has arrived he dashes towards it
before
anyone even recognizes he's left leading
to one of the best greetings i've seen
in all of one piece
a dust cloud forms on the horizon
whitebeard recognizes it as something
dangerous coming telling his crew to
stand behind him
then odin dashes into the clearing and
leaps into the air before clashing
swords with edward newgate of the
whitebeard pirates
as he does so he introduces himself and
asks let me write on your ship
what follows here is a really strong
moment of character on behalf of odin
which
cemented him as a best boy among the
secondary characters of the one piece
story for me he's charismatic he's brave
but
most importantly he has a strong value
system that takes priority over his own
desires to realize his dreams
whitebeard doesn't want him to come
along but as soon as he leaves odin
leaps from the coastline and grabs a
hold of a chain trailing after the ship
whitebeard says that if he can hold on
for three days he can come along and see
the world
now the reason why i praised this as a
strong character scene however becomes
clear when we shift focus and fast
forward almost three days later with
less than an hour left to hold on
odin now swollen and bruised from the
grueling trip he's been taken on as soon
as he hears a woman in danger
he leaps to her aid without hesitation
it's lady taki
the woman he will marry i just loved
this scene
as it was again a great way of
introducing the character we've already
heard so much about
and what's more is in seeing this the
same way odin has won over his other
followers
whitebeard became a fan of him out of
respect for what he's done here and now
referring to him as
little brother which i thought was a
really nice touch there are some great
moments of humor with lady talkie too as
all she wants to do is return to wano
and when odin and whitebeard hear that
after spending
all this effort to leave there their
faces are hilarious however
again i noticed something a little
interesting about this character
she lets everyone know that she's 26
years old and apparently from 800 years
in the past
meaning she has info regarding the void
century but
i'm curious as to why her age is
mentioned at all
and wonder if it's a coincidence that
her age here is the same as he already
in the present day storyline i mean it
probably is the coincidence but i just
thought it's strange that she told us
her exact age without much reason i
wonder if that information is necessary
for a deduction later
questions questions questions now this
is where things start to pick up and get
even more interesting sprinkled
throughout these flashback chapters are
snippets of orochi's life working as a
commoner and servant
originally working beneath yasue he
eventually through underhanded and
clever means
rises in the ranks of wano society
through the help of a particular old
woman wielding the power of
the clone clone fruit the very power
that we associate with bon clay
it's through this character we learn the
motivations orochi has for doing what
he's doing
apparently his grandfather kurozumi was
a daimyo of wano and in an effort to
become the heir of the throne
he poisoned all of the others however
when odin's father was born he was
forced to commit suicide leaving his
family name
disgraced through the manipulation of
this old lady's abilities and deceit
orochi climbed up to the highest
position in the land
proxy to the shogun of wano claiming
he'd hold this position for as long as
odin was away
now around this point in the story odin
has been gone for quite some time from
moana but he has been making a name for
himself
so much so he's now on the radar of one
none other than
gold d roger
[Music]
this video is brought to you by ridge
wallet most people are still using
wallets designed in the 1990s and in
this modern landscape it's seriously
outdated and i should know i've been
using the same wallet since i was 15
years old and that means i've been using
some outdated wallet for the last 14
years of my life
in the same way phones have gotten more
practical and compact over the last few
decades so too have wallets and
it's honestly made a massive difference
to my pockets personally i hate having
cumbersome items in there and this
totally fits my new lifestyle it holds
up to 12 separate cards
plus room for cash and there's over 30
different colors and styles including
carbon fiber and burnt titanium to
choose from
and if that wasn't enough to win you
over yet check out their thirty thousand
five star reviews the durable nature of
each of these wallets comes with a
lifetime warranty so
in theory you could buy this one wallet
and carry it for life and the rich team
have told me that they're so confident
that you like it that they'll actually
let you test drive it for 45 days that
means you can send it back for a full
refund if it's not up to your own
standards
right now there's a special offer going
where you can get 10 off
with free worldwide shipping and returns
and you can get all this by going to
ridge.com
not mark and using the coupon code not
mark at checkout
link is in the description
[Music]
there are many aspects to odin's
character that make him a lot like luffy
his determination to remain true to his
principles
in the face of his dreams being lost and
his desire to leap into action head
first without a plan being the other
he attacks gordy roger or at least
tries to but for the first time in this
flashback odin
is sent flying backwards roger is
massively powerful but unwilling to let
his family down
whitebeard dives into action to his
rescue their two weapons
not even touching creating a massive
shockwave across the area it's a
mammoth fight and one that lasts three
days and three nights
now having read over 950 chapters worth
of story to get to this point
the fact that whitebeard and roger have
such a large role to play in it is both
fascinating and massively enjoyable
there's a tremendous sense of fun with
roger but also a
quiet confidence in everything he does
much like gloofy actually
after this conflict the two camps come
together and exchange supplies
i love the goodwill that they have for
each other by the way it's really
refreshing
in these conversations roger discerns
that odin can read the poneglyphs and
thus
expresses tremendous interest in getting
him to come with on this journey
and what follows is this super engaging
story where we see roger more in one
chapter
than we have in perhaps the entire story
combined up until now giving us context
for a message that was written hundreds
and hundreds of chapters ago in skype
yet by roger and now we have
confirmation that he couldn't read it in
fact but needed odin instead
roger had just been guided to it by the
voices it emitted as i'm sure you can
guess based on the subject i'm chatting
about
those chapters cover the adventures of
odin aboard roger's crew
which honestly makes odin look far more
meek by comparison roger's quite
boisterous but more specifically they
detail the fascinating voyage
roger took in his final year trying to
gather all the road ponoglyphs having
already won in his possession that he
stole from big mom
knowledge of where another is and now
having learned the third is in one-o
he finally feels like his dream of
reaching raftel is
in sight which is interesting seeing as
we know that he's been pirating about
for the past 13 years i wonder if this
has only recently become part of his
goal
i suppose luffy could very well be
standing on the shoulders of giants in
this instance
throughout these few chapters we are
brought to various locations throughout
the world where we've already been like
skypia water 7 and fishman island all
places that we've been given small
indications here and there that roger
had been there in the past
but now we have context for it it's a
really awesome trip down memory lane and
one that i can say feels like a massive
reward for getting to know this universe
so well
over the last 950 chapters however when
lady toki falls ill and they approach
wano she insists that odin stay on this
voyage with roger and leave wano behind
until his journey is complete this is a
really tough scene for two reasons odin
has been the sort of free-spirited man
to always seek out adventure wherever he
can go
and now he finds himself being drawn
back to his home specifically because
his family is
now there but secondly there's something
majorly negative
after happening to wano it's changed he
hasn't been home in over four years at
this time
and it's difficult to leave it once
again knowing that his loved ones are
there and that his help is needed for
his country
odin is becoming a man the rest of this
tale ties up rather quickly they stop
off at zou to see the final road
poneglyph and make their way to the
final destination
shanks and buggy didn't make it for
honestly reasons that feel a little
forced but i'll let it slide and that's
when we see it
[Music]
chapter 967 the final two pages
the most spectacular close-up of the
series and it's goldie roger
laughing his heart out it's revealed
through odin's journal entries that they
are the first ones to have arrived there
in over 800 years
they can confirm that the one piece is
real they learn what the 100 year void
is what the will of d is and what the
ancient weapons
are and that wano was once open to the
rest of the world
this is the single biggest card ever
dangled in front of me
from this entire series and this portion
of the long odin flashback concerning
roger was sort of a one piece greatest
hits into and of itself
sort of in the same way end game is the
mcu's greatest hits throughout this
massive journey we've all undertaken
together to see roger and odin travel
across the ocean
arriving at various locations leaving
the breadcrumbs that luffy would
ultimately find was such a surreal
experience
and following the trail of the road
ponoglyphs was really fun too
but when we got to laugh tale
for me not to see anything but odin's
journal entry and their expressions was
a fantastic choice
no backgrounds just characters and it
makes me wonder why they're laughing
obviously
for all the secrets of the world to be
in that one spot too
it gives us a great goal to shoot for
everything we need is right there
we just gotta get to it i guess we are
really now
in the end game something that did catch
my attention however immediately
afterwards was the first page and first
panel of
chapter 968 in it we see once again
odin's journal entry
citing that when roger returned shanks
came to him and
asked him something only to shed tears
afterwards i'm not sure if this has
something to do with roger's impending
illness and death which i'm still not
convinced of just yet or if it has to do
with something entirely different
i honestly don't have anything to
speculate on but it might have something
to do with going to the east blue
perhaps but that could very well be a
stretch
needless to say it'd be interesting to
learn the contents of this particular
conversation
odin returns to wano this is the portion
of the story that begins to tug on your
heartstrings and drag you down
into a desperate abyss the likes of
which only older the crazy genius could
bring you down to
naturally once odin arrives home to his
wife lady toki and his two children he's
also made aware of the terrible
circumstances that have befallen one out
the once pristine landscape of the
country is slowly changing as
pirates of factory chimneys jut out from
the horizon after council from his
trusted samurai he hears
tales of the slave camps the torment and
the injury lady toki sustained at the
hands of these vile individuals
incensed odin launches into action
bounding towards the flower capital
into the quarters and up to a petrified
orochi however it quickly becomes
apparent that conflict won't win in this
instance
orochi has surrounded himself with some
terribly powerful people but for the
first time perhaps in his entire life
thanks to the work of lady taki the
samurai and the growing interest to see
orochi's tyranny meet and end
the people of wano are ready to accept
odin as their hero
[Music]
when i turned the page and saw this
panel my heart
sank now there's clearly more to this
than might meet the eye but this is
easily one of the most effective page
turns in the entire series for me
successfully building up the person odin
is and the following he's gathered all
the while establishing a sense that the
people of wano view him as a returning
hero to free them from the vile human
being in orochi
in doing this oda puts us into the shoes
of the town's people as they watch on in
defeatist
disbelief this was supposed to be the
man to save them all but instead he's
dancing like a fool in the streets for
change
continuing to do so for five long years
until one day orochi and his crew march
into curry the town where odin is
residing
citing that wano will be a weapons
manufacturer this
shatters odin and for him it's the last
straw and together with his akizaya 9 he
does
just that marching towards a moment that
will go down in history as
the hour of legends it's revealed that
when odin confronted orochi back then
he chose the path that would lead to the
least hurt in his mind although she
promised that if he danced
every day he would save the people of
wano from being killed and tortured
and if he kept it up for five years then
orochi and kaido would sail away
in the ships that they were building but
this
did not happen
incensed with purpose and anger now
stands odin and his forces before kaido
in one of the most intimidating scenes
in the series having been manipulated
into giving kaido and his forces time to
build in strength now on one
side stands 11 samurai and on the other
1
000 pirates it's a fierce and bloody
struggle and the conflict is captured
brilliantly through these wonderful
drawings but this
is when odin gains the upper hand
using these two swords slicing through
the strong height of kaido dealing
serious damage
but then he sees his son
however it was just a distraction a
mirage created by the clone clone fruit
and that minor momentary distraction was
all kaido needed to take odin out
the battle was won in that instance the
samurai and odin are now imprisoned
awaiting a terrifying death sentence
they are going to be boiled to death
and this once again is in the same way
he came into the story
odin leaves it accepting a terrible
situation in the face of harrowing
consequences
on behalf of other people citing that if
he can survive holding his companions
above his head
safe from their boiling oil face for one
hour they can go free
and the crazy part is he does it
for one full hour his body is cooked by
the boiling
oil around him all the while holding his
friends above a grim
grim death easily the most heroic story
of the series for me
and one that shook me to my very core
when i read what happened next
knowing full well that he will last a
full hour at the last minute orochi
changes the sentence to death
by firing squad and with that odin
launches his friends into the sky
telling them to flee and to open oneo's
borders
and with that they dash into the
distance now driven by new purpose
odin however he wasn't so lucky shot by
kaido between the eyes his last words
being
build your strength while you can for i
am a story to accompany your drinks
this heinous and cruel action saddens
everyone deeply but sends denjiro
into an intense rage that contorts his
face leading him to go by kyoshiro
the mad thereafter in the following
chapter we then finally get a chance to
see how the events of lady taki and the
samurai got thrust into the future with
momonosuke and how hiyori found herself
to be where she ultimately ended up
thanks to the helping hand of kyoshiro
these flashback sequences were a breath
of fresh air and some of my favorite
moments from the entire series i think
it should go without saying that this
large flashback is the single best
flashback sequence from the entire story
bar none introducing us to a brilliant
and lovable character in odin as he
gains friendship
a sense of duty maturity and family all
the while traveling across the world in
search of adventure but the next
sequence of events
brought such an overwhelming flood of
emotion to the surface for me i simply
had to dedicate this portion of the
video to chapters 9 7
4 and 9 7 5. effectively the last 18
chapters and
well really the last few acts have been
building at least in part
to this moment the moment where the
rebellion they had all fought so
fiercely to keep hope alive for
and no one is here as an audience we are
now armed with the experiences of
all the loyal followers ready to lay
down their lives
my heart felt heavy and sunken as i
watched these poor broken men and women
stand before the roaring
fierce angry seas totally utterly alone
after all the hard work they had put
into bringing this planet into action
surrounded by destruction they suspect
that once again the word must have
gotten back to orochi concerning the new
plan
and where it was taking place getting
aboard this tiny boat setting towards
certain doom
they come to understand that it must be
one of them and then
this happens
this single panel sends shivers down my
spine the likes of which i don't think
i'll ever forget and it makes perfect
sense going all the way back to when we
first met up with kenduro in dressrosa
of all the samurai they met along the
way
all who cried upon seeing each other
kanjuro was the only one not to show any
emotion
and the first thing he asks is about
momonosuke's status
what's more is that dotted throughout
this vast story are panels that give
hints to this character being the bad
guy
all along and that's honestly what i
love to see in storytelling
after he reveals who he truly is a
member of the same kurozumi clan
orochi's part of kaido's massive
warships begin steamrolling forward
towards their small dinghy enraged by
this news kinemon slices off kenjuro's
head
but it's not him it's a perfect copy but
kanjuro could never really draw that
well well this
is about where i had it points out to me
that he had all this time
been using his non-dominant hand to draw
everything and at every turn
tried to prevent progress and
furthermore he was the one that led
kaido's forces to zou in the first place
at this point i was totally and
completely floored by the competence of
this swerve
never in all of my life have i ever
experienced a story swerve
exactly how the author intended me to so
perfectly
this chapter captured my imagination
like none other in this series and
brought every single shred of hope
crashing down to the lowest they have
ever been in the series and now that oda
has taken us to as low as he can
possibly go
now is the time to inject hope back into
the series
suddenly out of nowhere cannons from
three vessels meet their mark on kaido's
monstrous ships
finally breaking the cycle of despair
seeing him for the very first time in so
many
chapters stands luffy pictured alongside
law and kid
ready to take on kaido in the span of 17
pages oda had me crying tears of sadness
and utter relief what an outstandingly
brilliant storyteller
and it's not over yet in the next
chapter oda raises our spirits again
again
as orochi and kaido ready for the
festivities on the island luffy
kid and law attacked their battleships
and to make matters even better
kyoshiro is now here revealing that he
is in fact dengiro
to everybody much to the dismay of the
traitor he sought to outsmart
and outsmart but the true gigabrain play
of the entire rebellion has to be from
kinaemon
convincing the traitor that the
rebellion was taking place on the tokage
port
and not the wharf even hiding numbers
from kanjiro that proved to be crucial
in the closing moments of this encounter
my mind man my mind is fried in the most
beautiful way
kinemon with the galaxy brain play that
saved
the day
i honestly don't think i've ever been
more happy reading a story in
all of my life sincerely a
heart-wrenching heartbreaking
breathtaking uplifting and harrowing
moment
that sends shivers to my very core wano
is
easily the best arc in one piece for me
like i know it's not even done yet but
even if all oda did was print 2.5 more
acts of blank pages
this would still be better than anything
he's ever done in my opinion and while
this
isn't the end of where the manga is
currently right now
i think it's where i'm gonna end my
review while also offering and
encouraging anyone who can't wait for my
next review of one piece to drop to
instead pick up this incredible story
and read through it for yourselves this
really is a tale that deserves to be
supported
and experienced first hand over the last
half a year i've dedicated myself to
catching up to the one piece story
and to document it as authentically as i
can to give you all my blind review of
this wonderful series that's captured
the hearts of millions young and old
throughout the world i think it goes
without saying that this experience has
exceeded any and all high expectations i
had before entering into this
self-imposed challenge
and this quite simply couldn't have been
done without my incredible editor
or my one piece team backing me up the
entire way i'll never be able to grow up
with this series like i did with dragon
ball
but during the time i wrote and reviewed
this incredible tale of heisi's
adventure
i've moved into my first home gotten
engaged and gained a new family member
so i guess i can say that one piece has
been there for some of the most
important moments of my life i can't
wait to continue this story with you all
but
until then as always i've been totally
not mark
and thank you so much for watching
why didn't no one tell me that this
story was like the best thing ever
but you'd be surprised how if i didn't
already love zorro's character this
would be the moment i'd propose to him
i might have fallen in love with him
there and then
piece of verve or life paper
[Music]
this wasn't the best arc so far
if a lot of people love each other the
world would be a better place to live
[Music]
you